hojear una revista es toda una
experiencia no es cómo desplazarse por
la pantalla de una tableta sin parar y
sin rumbo tener una revista en la mano
de soler un aroma particular el del
papel es acariciar un objeto escuchar el
sonido armonioso de las páginas que
pasan y revelar las imágenes serías de
imágenes comúnmente llamadas series de
moda como están diseñadas estas
fotografías que significan lujo dan bajo
weeks uno de los editores de moda con
más talento del mundo explica bill serie
matt settings trabajo te llegó a núcleo
una personalización story
y una serie de moda es una historia de
hecho en inglés lo llamamos fashion
story así que efectivamente estamos
haciendo una historia que es una
historia visual
ahora bien el error a veces es hacer o
construir una historia en la editorial
de moda como uno la construiría o en una
novela escrita o en una película el
error sería pensar que hay un comienzo
un nudo y un desenlace el error es
pensar que el personaje tiene una faceta
psicológica no no hay psicología hay un
modelo eso es que puede tener actitudes
que pueden inspirar una dimensión
psicológica pero no estamos en una
película no estamos en una novela
estamos haciendo fotos de moda y punto
el lector de la revista no sabe lo que
hay en nuestra cabeza no sabe cómo se
construyó la historia ve un resultado
desde la página 1 hasta hasta la última
página el resto no existe
lo holden bajo weeks se encuentra
actualmente en el estudio de bruselas
con su equipo para realizar la primera
parte de una serie sobre la moda
masculina
para mí si la moda es solo ropa no es
moda es ropa es un negocio es un montón
de otras cosas la moda no es sólo ropa
la moda es la imagen es nuestro tiempo
es el físico es el estado de ánimo es
muchas cosas más que la ropa como
elegimos la ropa no es ningún secreto en
el sector de las revistas en francia o
en el resto del mundo
trabajamos con anunciantes con
publicidad por lo que es normal y nada
vergonzoso poner a nuestros socios por
delante y valorarnos pero ahora tenemos
que averiguar cómo es decir encontrar en
las colecciones lo que mejor se adapte
al tipo de historia que vamos a contar
tratar de encontrar los looks más
interesantes
y también digamos los que coinciden lo
más posible con la identidad de la
revista no vas a fotografiar lo mismo si
se trata de una revista como citizen
kane que para no sé qué otra revista hay
que estar en el corazón de que es la
revista el editor de moda lo tiene en
cuenta y hace de la identidad de la
revista la parte central de su trabajo
al ojo donde ojo weeks ex cineasta
creador de imágenes consultor de marcas
le gusta construir historias entre otras
para la revista series en que un
trimestral tan grueso como una guía
telefónica que se vende a un euro
gracias a la omnipresencia de la
publicidad teatral extravagante lujosa
irreverente impetuosa caprichosa como su
fundador viejo van beek a por el hombre
es el de la generación palés de los años
70 y 80 y el periódico ha mantenido sus
excentricidades exquisito sabor black
duck y tapó de la provocación la
excentricidad va más allá de la
apariencia y la provocación aunque la
provocación a través de la apariencia
sea el núcleo de la noción de
excentricidad pero está claro que la
excentricidad el excéntrico es el que va
en contra de la norma de las
convenciones de lo que la sociedad
espera de nosotros en general así que sí
excéntrico por supuesto que significa
algo
la segunda parte del rodaje tiene lugar
en un vivero especializado en arte a tu
diario una pasión para el ojo de mojo
weeks a quien le encanta podar sus
propios bosques la coherencia del
escenario
eduard manos de tijera la película de
culto de tim burton que es el tema de
esta serie de moda
alguna caja de mí
[Música]
así que mantuvimos pero un poco de
manera diferente un poco revisada un
poco digerida el vínculo con esta
estética digamos que está entre el
steampunk y el gótico pero que no
mantuvimos como punto de vista principal
de la moda
por otro lado la película que enfrenta a
edward en su esplendor y aislamiento con
el resto del mundo
no queríamos enviar ese mensaje nos
dijimos este personaje inspirado en
edward cuando está por fin cuando se
enfrenta a otros a otras personas
bueno aquí modela bueno su estilo su
humor es contagioso
[Música]
así que no creamos dos mundos diferentes
entre el personaje inspirado en edward y
los demás sino que los unimos en una
sola estética como si la excentricidad
fuera contagiosa decidimos presentar la
excentricidad como un valor positivo sé
creativo sé tú mismo sé diferente solo
será algo bueno
elogio de la alteridad reconocer al otro
en su extravagancia diferencia e incluso
discordancia si los desfiles de moda no
cuentan historias pueden tener una
maravillosa moraleja
[Música]